do you think about your
own mortality you said uh
you know we're young the the
the the possibility of doing all kinds
of crazy things it's still out there
it's still
before us but uh it can end any moment
do you think about your own
ending at any moment
unfortunately i think about way too way
too much
it's somehow after roman like every year
after that i started losing people that
i really
love i lost my grandfather next year
my you know the the person who would
explain to me you know what
the universe is made off while you're
selling apples
while selling apples and then i lost
another close friend of mine and
um and it just made me very
scared i have tons of fear about death
that's what makes me
not fall asleep oftentimes and just go
in loops and
um and then as my therapist you know
recommended me i open up uh some
nice calming images with the voice over
and it calms me down oh for sleep
yeah i'm really scared of that this is a
big i definitely have tons of
i guess some pretty big trauma about it
and i'm still working it through
there's a philosopher ernest becker
who wrote a book denial of death i'm not
sure if you're familiar with any of
those folks
um there's a in psychology a whole field
called terror management theory
sheldon was just on the podcast he wrote
the book he was the
we talked for four hours about death uh
fear of death uh but his whole idea is
that um
ernest becker i think i i find this idea
really compelling
is uh that everything human beings have
created
like our whole motivation in life
is to uh create like escape death
is to try to uh construct an illusion
of um that we're somehow immortal
it's like everything around us this room
your startup your dreams
all everything you do is a kind of um
creation of a brain
unlike any other mammal or species is
able to be cognizant of the fact that it
ends for us
i think so you know there's the question
of like the meaning of life that
you know you look at like what drives us
uh
humans and when i read ernest becker
that i highly recommend people read
is the first time i the scene it felt
like this is the right
thing at the core uh sheldon's work is
called warm at the core
so he's saying it's i think it's uh
william james he's quoting or
whoever is like the the thing
what is it the core of it all sure
there's like love
you know jesus might talk about like
love is at the core of
everything i i don't you know that's the
open question what's it the
you know it's turtles turtles but it
can't be turtles all the way down what's
what's at the at the bottom and uh
ernest becker says the fear of death
and the way in fact
uh because you said therapist and
calming images his whole idea is um
you know we we want to bring that fear
of death as close as possible
to the surface because it's uh
and like meditate on that uh and
and use the clarity of vision that
provides to uh
you know to live a more fulfilling life
to um
to live a more honest life to discover
you know there's something about you
know being cognizant of the finiteness
of it all
that might result in um in the most
fulfilling life
so that's the that's the duel of what
you're saying because you kind of said
it's like i
unfortunately think about it too much
it's a question whether it's good to
think about it because i i've
i'm again i talk about way too much
about love and probably death
and when i ask people or
friends which is why i probably don't
have many friends
are you afraid of death i think most
people say
they're not they're not what they they
say they're um
they're afraid you know it's kind of
almost like they see death
as this kind of like a paper deadline or
something and they're afraid not to
finish the paper before the paper like
like i'm afraid not to finish um
the goals i have but it feels like
they're not actually
realizing that this thing ends like
really realizing
like really thinking as nietzsche and
all these philosophers like thinking
deeply about it
like uh the very thing that
you know like when you think deeply
about something you can dis
you can realize that you haven't
actually thought about
it uh yeah and i
and when i think about death it's like
it can be it's terrifying if it feels
like stepping outside into the cold
or it's freezing and then i have to like
hurry back inside or it's warm
uh but like i think there's something
valuable about stepping out
there into the freezing cold uh
definitely
when i talk to my mentor about it he
always uh
tells me well what dies
there's nothing there that can die but i
guess that
works um
well in in buddhism one of the concepts
are really hard to
grasp and that people spend all their
lives meditating on would be
anata which is the concept of not self
and kind of thinking that you know if
you're not your thoughts which you're
obviously not your thoughts because you
can observe them and not your emotions
and not
your body then what is this and if you
go really far
then finally you see that
there's not self there's this concept of
not self so
once you get there how can that actually
die what is dying
right you're just a bunch of molecules
stardust
but that is very um you know very
advanced
um spiritual work for me i'm definitely
just definitely not oh my god no i have
uh
i think it's very very useful it's just
the fact that maybe being so afraid is
not useful and mine is more
i'm just terrified like it's really
makes me um at a personal level on a
personal level
i'm terrified
how do you overcome that i don't
i'm still trying to have pleasant images
well pleasant images get me uh to sleep
and then during the day i can distract
myself with other things
like talking to you i'm glad we're both
doing the same exact thing okay good
[Laughter]
is there other like is there moments
since you've uh lost roman that you had
like moments of
like bliss and like that you've
forgotten
that you have achieved that buddhist
like level of
like what can possibly die i'm part
like uh losing yourself in the moment in
the ticking
time of like this universe he's just
part of it
for a brief moment and just enjoying it
well that goes hand in hand i remember i
think a day or two after he died we
went to finally get his passport out of
the embassy and
we're driving around moscow and it was
you know december which is
usually there's never sun in moscow in
december
and somehow it was an extremely sunny
day and we were driving with
a close friend
and i remember feeling for the first
time maybe this just moment of um
incredible clarity and somehow happiness
not like happy happiness but happiness
and just feeling
that you know um
i know what the universe is sort of
about whether it's good or bad
um and it wasn't a sad feeling it was
probably the most beautiful feeling that
you can ever
um achieve and you can only
get it when something oftentimes when
something traumatic like that happens
um but also if you just you really spend
a lot of time
meditating looking at the nature doing
something that really gets you there
but once you're there i think when you
uh summit a mountain a really hard
mountain
you inevitably get there that's just a
way to get to the state
but once you're on this in this state um
you can do really big things i think
yeah sucks it doesn't last forever
so bukowski talked about like love is
the fog
like it's uh when you wake up in the
morning it's
it's there but it eventually dissipates
it's really sad
nothing lasts forever but definitely
like doing this push-up and running
thing
there's moments at a couple moments
like i'm not a crier i don't cry but
there's
moments where i was like face down on
the carpet
like with tears of my eyes is
interesting and then that like complete
like uh there's a lot of demons
i've got demons had to face them funny
how running makes you face your demons
but
at the same time the flip side of that
there's a few moments where i was
in bliss and all of it alone
which is funny it's beautiful
i like that but definitely pushing
yourself physically one of it for sure
yeah it's yeah like you said i mean
you were speaking as a metaphor of mount
everest but
it also works like literally i think
physical endeavor somehow
yeah there's something i mean war
monkeys apes
whatever physical there's a physical
thing to it
but there's something to this pushing
yourself physical
physically but alone that happens when
you're doing like things like you do or
strenuous like
workouts or you know rolling across the
atlantic
or yeah like marathons that's why i love
watching marathons
and you know so boring
but you can see them getting there so
the other thing
i don't know if you know there's a guy
named david goggins
he's uh he basically uh
so he's been either email on the phone
with me every day through this so i
haven't been exactly alone
but he he's kind of
he's the he's the devil on the devil's
shoulder
so he's like the worst possible human
being
in terms of giving you a advice like
he has um through everything i've been
doing he's been doubling everything i do
so he he's insane uh he's a this navy
seal person
uh he's wrote this book can't hurt me
he's basically one of the toughest human
beings on earth he
ran all these crazy ultra marathons in
the desert he set the world record a
number of pull-ups
he just does everything where's like
he like how can i suffer today he
figures that out and does it
yeah that um whatever that is uh that
process of self-discovery
is really important i actually had to
turn myself off from the internet
mostly because i started this like
workout thing like a happy go-getter
with my like headband and like like
just like uh because a lot of people
were like inspired and they're like yeah
we're gonna exercise with you
and i was yeah great you know but then
like
i realized that this this journey can't
be done
together with others this has to be done
alone
you